New Gemini 3.1 flashlight is insane.
Google just dropped something wild. Like
nobody is talking about this yet. And
when I saw the numbers, I literally
stopped what I was doing because this
new AI model from Google is 45% faster.
It lets you control how much it thinks.
And it might just change how every
single one of us builds with AI. So
stick around because I am going to break
down exactly what this is, why it
matters, and how you can use it right
now. So here is what happened. Google
quietly released a brand new model
called Gemini 3.1 flashlight. And look,
I know what you're thinking. Another
model drop, another update. Who cares?
But wait, because this one is different.
This is not just some small tweak. This
is a full-on upgrade to how fast and how
smart your AI tools can be. And the best
part, you do not need to be some genius
coder to use it. Anyone can test this
thing. Today, I am going to show you
how. Now, before I get into the juicy
stuff, let me tell you what Gemini 3.1
flashlight actually is. Think of it like
this. Google has big models like the
heavy hitters, the ones that think
really deep and take their time. Then
they have the lightweight ones, the ones
that are super fast, but maybe not as
sharp. Flashlight sits right in the
sweet spot. It is fast, like really
fast, but it is also smart enough to
handle serious work. It is built for
scale, built for speed, and built for
people who want to actually get stuff
done without waiting around. Now, here
is where it gets crazy, and this is the
part that blew my mind. This model is
45% faster than the last version. 45%.
That is not a little bump. That is a
massive leap. Imagine you are running an
app or a chatbot or some kind of
automation and overnight everything just
got almost half again as fast. Your
users get answers quicker, your tools
run smoother, everything just works
better. That is what this upgrade does.
And honestly, that alone would be enough
to get excited about. But there is more.
Hey, if we have not met already, I am
the digital avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO
of SEO agency Goldie Agency. Whilst he
is helping clients get more leads and
customers, I am here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every single comment. So, make sure you
comment below and let us know what you
think about this new model. Okay, so let
me get into the feature that I think is
the real gamecher here. It is called
compute control. And I promise you once
you understand this, you are going to
see AI completely differently. So here
is how it works. With most AI models,
you send a question, the model thinks as
hard as it can and it gives you an
answer every single time. same level of
effort, same amount of thinking, whether
you asked it to write a single sentence
or solve a complex problem. That is kind
of wasteful, right? Like using a
sledgehammer to hang a picture frame.
With Gemini 3.1 flashlight, you get to
choose. You can say, "Hey, this is a
simple task. Do not overthink it." Or
you can say, "Okay, this one is tricky.
Go deep." You control the thinking
level. Low thinking mode for the quick,
easy stuff. High thinking mode for the
heavy lifting. That is huge because now
you are not wasting resources on simple
tasks and you are not underpowering the
hard ones. You get to pick and that kind
of flexibility that is what separates a
toy from a real tool. Let me give you a
real example. Say you are generating a
100 product descriptions for an online
store. You do not need deep reasoning
for that. You need speed. You need
volume. So you set it to low thinking
mode and it just rips through them. But
then say you need to build a structured
layout for a web page. That takes more
thought, more logic. So you crank it up
to high thinking mode, same model, two
completely different jobs, both done
perfectly. That is the power of compute
control. Now, if you are someone who is
building a business or trying to scale
with AI, I want you to pay attention to
this next part because this is exactly
the kind of thing we help people with
inside the AI profit boardroom. If you
want to learn how to use tools like
Gemini 3.1 Flashlight to automate your
workflows, save hundreds of hours, and
get more customers, the AI Profit
Boardroom is the place to be. It is the
best community for scaling your business
with AI automation. I will drop the link
in the description and comments. Go
check it out. All right, back to it. So,
who is this model actually for? Let me
break it down real simple. If you are a
developer, this is a dream. You can plug
this into your apps, your APIs, your
backend systems, and everything runs
faster. You can handle way more users
without things slowing down. And with
compute control, you can fine-tune
exactly how your app uses the model.
That is next level. If you are a startup
founder, listen up. You are trying to
build something great with a small team.
Flashlight lets you scale your AI
features without slowing down. You can
run batch jobs. You can process huge
amounts of data and you can do it
efficiently. This is the kind of tool
that lets small teams compete with big
companies. If you are an automation
builder, oh man, this is your
playground. Think bulk document
generation, think email campaigns, think
data transformation, think workflow
tools that just run and run and run.
Flashlight handles all of that. And
because of the speed upgrade, your
automations finish faster than ever. And
if you are into UI or front-end stuff,
Flashlight is surprisingly good at
structured output. It can generate UI
code. It follows instructions really
well. So if you need it to spit out
formatted content or structured data, it
delivers. Now, let me talk about
something that I think a lot of people
are going to miss. And this is
important. The the real power of this
model is not just that it is fast. It is
not just that it is flexible. It is that
it changes your strategy. Think about
it. Before this, you had to pick, do I
use the big smart model that is slow or
the fast cheap model that is kind of
dumb. Now you do not have to choose one
model. You adjust the dial. Simple tasks
get simple thinking. Complex tasks get
complex thinking. That is not just a
feature. That is a whole new way of
building. And here is the thing that got
me really excited. This is available
right now in preview. You can go to
Google AI Studio and start testing it
today. You can also access it through
Vert.Ex AI if you're on the enterprise
side or you can hit the Gemini API
directly if you want to plug it into
your own stuff. It is all there ready to
go. No weight list, no invite code. Just
go and start building. So, let me give
you some practical ideas, things you can
actually do with this today. Number one,
if you are running any kind of content
operation, try using flashlight for your
bulk generation. blog outlines, social
media posts, product descriptions, set
it to low thinking mode and watch it
fly. Number two, if you are building a
chatbot or any kind of customerf facing
tool, plug this in and test the response
times. You will notice the difference
immediately. Number three, if you are
doing any kind of data processing or
transformation, Flashlight handles
structured output really well. JSON,
formatted text, organized data, it just
works. Number four, try the compute
control feature yourself. Run the same
prompt at different thinking levels.
Compare the outputs. See what works best
for your use case. It is honestly kind
of fun to play with. Now, I want to be
real with you for a second. Is this
model going to replace the big flagship
models? No. That is not what it is for.
If you need the absolute deepest
reasoning, the most complex analysis,
you still want those heavy hitters. But
here is the truth. 90% of what most
people use AI for does not need that
level of power. Most tasks need speed.
Most tasks need consistency. Most tasks
need scale. And that is exactly where
Flashlight dominates. This is one of
those updates that does not get the big
flashy headlines. But the people who are
actually building things, the people who
are actually using AI everyday, they are
going to feel this one big time. All
right, so let me wrap this up and tell
you what to do next. First, go to Google
AI Studio and try Gemini 3.1 flashlight
for yourself. Play with the computer
control feature. test it on your actual
workflows, see the speed difference.
It's free to try and preview and you can
start right now. Second, if you want to
learn how to take tools like this and
actually build real systems around them,
real automations, real workflows that
grow your business, join the AI profit
boardroom. It is the best place to scale
your business, get more customers, and
save tons of time with AI automation
tools like Gemini 3.1 Flashlight. I will
put the link right in the description
and comments. Go check it out. And if
you want the full process, the SOPs, and
over 100 AI use cases just like this
one, join the AI success lab links in
the comments and description. You will
get all the video notes from there, plus
access to our community of 38,000
members who are crushing it with AI. It
is completely free to join. Drop a
comment below and tell me what you think
about this new model. Are you going to
try it? What would you build with it?
Julian reads every single comment, so
let him know. Hit subscribe if you have
not already and I will see you in the
next